ben wallace secretary of state for
defense thank you for joining us this
morning let's go straight to your
remarks and i'll follow up with some
questions i know you're on the side
central
yes thank you andrew and uh i'm i think
what i would like to do if that's all
right is i'll keep my remarks fairly
short and leave it to questions from you
and others because i think
uh that is probably
a good way to get to the bottom of
people's uh thoughts on global britain
and you know what is defense for in a
global britain and i i think what i
would say is i'm here
at pghq which is the
organization that coordinated or pitting
and that extraordinary evacuation from
kabul
which i think by any military feat was
an extraordinary success
and while it's regretful we left
people behind we took over 15 and a half
thousand people out
over uh 14 days
165 flights uh and also we put in
over a thousand soldiers and brought
them out again so it was an
extraordinary
uh piece of military uh a display of
military competence in a very difficult
scenario uh we didn't know how bad it
could get we plan for the worst and we
hope for the best we predominantly got
somewhere in between
but we had all the capability if we had
to
deal with a worse situation i think for
you know the title of today's speech you
know future of defensive liberation the
question is what is global britain i i
said recently in your
in an interview in the spectator that uk
is no longer a superpower
but it is a global power and i think
there is
a difference and you know what are those
powers well there's hard power which for
in my job as defense secretary is the
bread and butter of what i do in the
department generating uh a hard power if
necessary
uh and generating responses to threats
we meet every day and
often our characteristics you know we
are a p5 nation a nuclear capable
nation with nuclear weapons
and we are
you know globally capable with our
defense capabilities our aircraft
carrier british built built in recycled
currently in japan exercising with a
whole load of nations
and we obviously have some of the most
highly professional men and women
in our forces equipped with both
sovereign capabilities and sometimes
internationally collaborated
capabilities such as the typhoon and the
f-35 aircraft we also have our soft
power levers
economic power cultural power and
anything we should ever underestimate
wherever we go in the world our
influence to our culture and our
language matters
uh and is i think one of the best ways
that we extend our influence around the
world and stand up for our values and
you know the most obvious one is the
likes of the bbc world service but just
our language and what we can contribute
to the world in education and science
power is another
i think a standalone culture but our
science power is and can be a superpower
uh like andrew is scott whose family
went around the world using their
education in the 19th century the 20th
century we took our education we got
from scotland and used that to build
railways and engineers as my family did
in india etc and all of that
i think is what our powers are and they
are at a global
level globally competitive
and can genuinely if coordinated
properly
extend our ability to influence the
world and to stand up for our values and
i think that's
really what a global britain is it is
recognizing we're a global power
and then if we
come together coordinate properly either
with friends and allies but also within
our own government to use those tools we
can further our interest and that was
the point of the integration review
and the point about my defense review
was a recognition
that we have to be able to do more than
just the war fight we have to be able to
be
in this day and age an enabler
because we're not always going to have
the same bilateral partners
of course the united states will be our
closest military ally
and our partner of choice
and has for decades been the guarantee
of european security and it is
incredibly important that we maintain
that
but on many threats and issues we face
it won't always be the case the united
states will choose to be with us
and if there are lessons from both the
trump administration and the tax today
is
the united states messaging is don't
take us for granted and i think we have
to make sure that we don't take it for
granted and enable our armed forces
to build bilateral trilateral
partnerships around problems we will
agree with
and i think that is where britain can
play a strong role as an enabling
defense power where we come
along and we bring our framework in the
same way the united states brought a
framework to
afghanistan
towards the end there was very little
u.s ground troops but there was always
that enabler of air power or isr
intelligence surveillance and
reconnaissance capabilities and i think
that is
one of the key roles that our defense
paper was about it was also a
recognition that
no one really wants to deal with failed
states you want to try and stop them
failing in the first place because the
real expense the real cost of lives
the real explosion of poverty comes when
a state fails we need forces that we can
configure
to
prevent
a conflict sometimes occurring and
that's why we invested in what we call
the range of battalions but similar to
the u.s
green beret battalions which are people
that will go and work alongside nations
to improve their resilience before
things get bad and in parts of africa
there is a very good example of that is
you know it is in our interest for
example that al-shabab and somalia
doesn't get more powerful it is in our
interest that they don't destabilize
neighbouring countries and therefore the
way to assist those countries is help
their resilience getting in early uh not
just training but sometimes sometimes if
they wish it or if the political will is
there in the uk
to accompany them to enable them in
their operations and therefore that's
how we improve their resilience and then
the other part of our thoughts and
configuration is to we have to be able
to operate
sub-threshold because in all those tools
that i talked about
both hard power but also the soft
economic cultural science our
adversaries are rampant and out clay
they don't have the same regard for
necessarily economic rules or science uh
propriety and you know respect of ip
and therefore we have to be able to in
defense and in other parts of the
government operate below the threshold
of open war armed conflicts we have to
prepare our forces
uh to be able to challenge or push back
sometimes in the shadows and i would
include in that cyber you know the work
we have to do to protect our equities
uh through cyber either through
offensive cyber if that is required or
defensive cyber
through our special forces making sure
that they move with the times
that they're able to deliver effects
below the threshold
of open warfare
and that's why you know we need
as defense secretary my job is often to
provide the options for the rest of
government they won't always be taken
but you don't want to be a defense
secretary that when a prime minister in
10 years or 20 years
turns around and says i need this
capability to be the defense secretary
who says i don't have that on the shelf
you know my job is to provide those
options i'm not the necessarily the
leader of how to apply those options
i am there to provide
uh stack the shelves so to speak on some
occasions because
we have to cover all uh aspects and i
think
the real question for me is i was
incredibly lucky the prime minister
granted me a four-year spender
settlement he granted me a
large spending uh settlement the biggest
since the cold war some of that was
genuinely about filling the black holes
that we had inherited
but also some of it allows me headroom
to modernize uh large parts of the armed
forces and of course we get into the
debate about mass versus
uh you know
speed and readiness and agility
and that will always happen and people
will talk about the size of the army and
is it big enough or strong enough well
in 2014 there were about 120 000 plus
soldiers in afghanistan
and that didn't stop where we are today
it's not always about the mass you can
deliver on the ground sometimes it is
but that's why we have international
partnerships and consortium britain's
never had the mass probably not since
the 20s to deliver
a sort of unilateral scale la
persistent conflict that's why we had
nato that's why we relied so heavily on
the commonwealth soldiers in the second
world war i mean the eighth army in
north africa was not just british
soldiers it was uh you know australians
and new zealands and commonwealth
soldiers delivering that we've always
needed those type of alliances we will
still need them
i think the question is how much
how much do we are we prepared to burn
share how much are other nations prepare
to furniture to get those alliances
and how much are we prepared to have a
resolve
because
it's one thing having lots of things on
paper but if when you're tested in your
resolve such as ukraine
if you do nothing
if if your your adversaries will spot
that so for me for example ukraine
matters because it's not just russia
that is watching which is china that is
watching afghanistan matters because
it's not just a taliban and al-qaeda in
afghanistan that matters that we have to
deal with
but it's also the islamist threat
elsewhere around the world who were also
watching what happened in july and
august so resolve is ultimately i think
the test for us all in the west
but i think
defense in a global britain
is about providing those range of
options both hard power both software
and bringing it all together
to address the threat
and that is the thing i have tried to
strive most in this department is to
make us a threat orientated organization
not a collector of things for top trump
so we can boast to each other's friends
around the international table what
we've got but are we addressing the
threat do we understand the threat and
once we can do that i think we can make
us safer in a more anxious and more
unstable world thank you
essentially thank you for that um
i hope you can hear me all right for
some reason
my neighbor seems to have started to
drill
uh so i hope that's not getting
the neighbors probably learned that i'm
his neighbor so that's probably why
they're trying to take a tunnel to get
out before the property prices collapse
completely but i hope it's not picking
up too much of that
let me pick up on some of the things you
you you said the secretary of state
did didn't our global britain ambitions
didn't didn't they end up on the dust of
kabul airport i mean the americans said
we're getting out we had to get out then
the americans said
we're closing down the airport operation
now we had to close down the operation
we couldn't do on our own and we didn't
seem to have any non-american allies
with the stomach to do without america i
mean that isn't that the harsh reality
well
the the the physical reality was the u.s
with the framework nation when they
wanted to leave
we had to leave um
could we have sent in the whole of 16
air assault brigade the whole of it
three battalions a whole brigade could i
have diverted a lot of my air
capabilities
uh handed over responsibilities and op
shader which is the syria iraq and
and held the air force yes we could have
done that we could have done that i
could have
mobilized greater parts of the army and
we could have chosen to uh you know go
to kabul maybe for a few months longer
or a year or maybe even a year plus but
but but what this was also about was
you know the history of afghanistan says
the only way you're going to address
that issue is as an international force
you know superpowers have tried before
unilaterally doing it you very quickly
become an
occupying force and occupying forces
have never voted well in
afghanistan and you would be effectively
in a fight
on your own for a year plus um
and i think the question was when there
was no other international resolve to
stay
our options whether you wanted to be
global britain or not were deeply
limited and i think it would have been
an unwise thing to stay on your own
without an international
uh support and the reason also is that
if you really want to
commit to helping afghanistan you need
that international team to work the
neighbors take menastat as pakistan
pakistan china russia you need a whole
of sort of nation approach network
international approach because it's got
to work on the economics etc and that
wasn't able and i think one of the
genuine questions is about the un you
know one other question we went as nato
with the us as a framework nation
um you know i i think there is a genuine
question to ask
uh you know
what is the in the 21st century how is
the u.n going to deal with failed states
because
it can't fix failed states then we are
in a difficult place
and if the u.n isn't for fixing failed
states what is it for
uh at some stages you know and i think
that if i look at mali andrew where we
can do our bit and the french have done
their bit with military force
the other bit the nation building the
counter corruption the education the
de-radicalization all the other parts of
what was called the algeria agreement
hasn't been delivered
so you're just doing military after
military but you're not changing and
we've seen i think two coups or one coup
in the last year
and i think that that is so i don't
think global britain can dust i actually
think what it proved was that my defense
command paper was on the right track
uh that that actually we need to be able
to be rapidly able to deliver other
bilateral multilateral
alliances should the ones we've taken
for granted not want to play in that
space
and that we should be there
we should also be configured for
post-conflict reconstruction better as
well
one of the lessons of iraq was we use an
armored brigade to defeat saddam hussein
brilliant roll that up that didn't take
long and then promptly replace them with
other armored brigades but in fact what
you're reading
was was replacing with brigade's design
for post-conflict reconstruction
you know no point sending another
cavalry regiment to do exactly what the
last one had done
no indeed and of course that ended in
basra which was not uh our finest r uh
can i
can i put this point to you in in recent
decades british military strategy
has
worked on the assumption that in nearly
every major military intervention we're
involved in will be alongside the
americans
after afghanistan is that still the
correct assumption
i think for major yes i i definitely
think for a major
intervention you know certainly we have
nato for if you could argue for that
north atlantic flank so in that part of
the world absolutely
article 5 and if you remember
our only article 5 deployment was
afghanistan
when
when the us called that and
uh so
absolutely i think we're talking about
major
but when it's about containing
uh potential destabilizing conflicts
that may not be the case
and uh i think there is a there is a
question for our european allies and for
ourselves about if we're going to do
things with other nations what's your
resolve you know are we really going to
do it
um and are you prepared to talk to your
public about the costs of fighting
sometimes for that freedom or that
resilience
uh and uh that that is a i think a
conversation is still to be had with the
public about the
i think appetite's the wrong word about
their tolerance
for
the cost you may have to you know the
blood and treasure you may have to spend
to protect your values but also protect
your allies
well if you look at the combination of
military capability and resolve
uh and you want to try and perhaps build
up a
a nato capability that doesn't rely so
much on the americans
you look at france
and you can see resolve and military
capability
where else do you look
in europe there is there is no
uh major
military capability or resolve
beyond the french is it not the truth
that as this decade goes on
we will have to be in much closer
military
alliance
post-brexit britain
with the french
i think you're right i mean i i have a
incredibly strong relationship with my
french counterpart um
i put a lot of effort into my french
counterpart uh maybe
first of all because we're equally
matched we're predominantly equally
sized
um secondly because our defence
industries also we are i mean if you
look at who actually buys things in
europe you know there's the french
there's uh the um the italians actually
you know they are quite they quite step
up to the plate and they are a keen
investor in the next generation of
fighter with britain
um
and actually italy in its own way is
quietly there often alongside us
uh but but you're right it's also why we
develop other types of alliances who fun
enough sometimes have less capability
but stronger resolve so we do quite a
lot in something called the jeff the
joint expeditionary force which is the
scandinavian the nordic countries plus
holland
and we not only train we operate and
exercise together and in that are two
former neutral countries sweden and
finland
um
and they funny enough because they're
close
to the shark they are absolutely fine
enough have greater resolve
then sometimes people a long way away or
further away and i think um
uh you but but overall you are right
that if we are going to
uh project power around the world to
sometimes intervene where we might have
to where if the us says well we'll we'll
enable but we won't put troops on the
ground then it's going to have to be
with the likes of france
uh
to be fair australia uh if we're talking
about the pacific there are nations in
the pacific
um but yes you're right i think your
observation is correct i don't think it
has to be done for an eu
uh model because i think funnily enough
just what you say francis is wedded to
its sovereignty and defense as anyone
else uh you know try getting the french
to act on behalf of uh
you know a unilateral european thing i
think it's easier said than done so
you're right we do work actually close
together
um and both my french counterpart and i
would often
vent our frustration in mali that you
know the french were doing quite a lot
of military we're supporting out there
with both chinook helicopters but also
in the u.n
and where was the un doing the rest of
the stuff you know uh so yes you're
right let me finish up because i know
you've got a busy schedule ahead and
we're running out of time the the the
strategic defense from you
uh
talked of a tilt to the indo-pacific
region
and also that that is now the
geopolitical fulcrum of events in the
indo-pacific uh
but although we make tilt in that
direction um is it surely the half truth
is that we would have no more than a
walk-on role in containing china i mean
if you look at during the cold war we
were the second most important member of
nato uh after america we were pivotal to
the defense of western europe and
nuclear power british army on the rhine
working hand in hand with the americans
uh we were the essential ally
particularly when in the early 60s under
the goal france dropped out effectively
from nato planning
but in the indo-pacific and we have some
assets we can bring there our
new aircraft carriers out there at the
moment but it's pretty marginal to the
america what the americans need i mean
the american allies there that really
matter japan south korea australia
taiwan india
all countries with big defense budgets
and increasing the defense budgets too
uh we we don't really matter that much
for the americans there do we
well
two things i came back in july i went to
visit i went to the united states i went
to indo-pacon the headquarters in hawaii
i went to japan i went to south korea i
went to vietnam
and right right around the world
and met with them all um ironically i
remember giving a speech in front of a
hammer and sickle in vietnam which was
uh
just a period
and
we shouldn't underestimate
our reach and influence in areas like
the soft power
and the british way of doing things so
when i talk about our global levers and
our global influence you know
um the americans do things in their way
and absolutely if you're setting out how
how many aircraft tanks and all that you
have
yes that britain isn't going to be
uh tilting with its hard power on mass
over to the pacific and as you say not
in a way that would uh
move the dial unilaterally
but you know japan wants to be partnered
with other nations in the g7 with
like-minded values it doesn't just want
a us
voice it has its own political
constituency it has to deal with
japan and south korea have traditional
historical
uh frictions let's call it that and it's
still there that are still there and
britain can play that
a really useful role which i found when
i was there of being that convener you
know off off of of not being the
american option options the wrong way
but but being you know
somehow recognized as quite an old power
you know the oldest defense agreement in
the pacific is the british fire power
defense agreement the fpda that's 50
years this year long before china became
in vogue you know and that's malaysia
that's singapore new zealand australia
and britain so
we we definitely have a role
uh in
in that uh sort of broader
internationalizing
a response whether it's freedom of
navigation whether it's you know
standing up to the vietnamese when their
fishing grounds are taken or when a
fishing boat was sunk by the chinese you
know they are they these are countries
some of them face similar problems to us
they are very dependent on china they
can't they can't get away from that but
they they get comfort in
our
uh our presence and are working together
but
and also those other tools economic
science and culture they are influential
in the pacific they still are you you
see britain's history all over it um and
and on india where i think everyone
wants india to play a greater role
i remember that you know the great
bricks of the great you know a few years
ago it was always going to be the bricks
for the next coming thing
india still has some way before it
decides it wants to and you can see that
in its military it has a has a
deep blue navy but it doesn't do many
deep blue exercises it does more inshore
than than far out and i think uh there
is still a way to go for india so i i
think you're right though but also we
shouldn't forget
that the tilt isn't just half power the
tilt is those soft powers economic signs
because that's
and also you don't have to go very far
to compete with china or russia right
you you know you the middle east is
still incredibly important to britain
africa is incredibly important you only
have to go to africa to see china
competing directly with british industry
and british business and british culture
and values you only have to go to africa
to see the russian mercenaries the
wagner group rampant in certain parts
and i often say to my cabinet colleagues
you don't have to go to taiwan straits
compete with china you actually only
have to go to africa or middle east uh
uh or even in other parts of
europe so so i think if if you know if
it's a global power that is your
competitor
you can compete anywhere in that globe
final quick question will
at least one of our two new aircraft
carriers
be pretty much on continuous deployment
in the pacific region with australian
and american and japanese perimeter
defense is that what we're going to do
it will be
[Music]
at least one will always be beyond the
north atlantic home beat i think let's
put it that way you know it won't be
every year we would go to the pacific
because my point about you know the
middle east is incredibly important the
indian ocean is incredibly important the
the charles de gaulle often would do
operations off the african coast against
uh islamist terrorism in west africa so
for us yes we're going to leave behind
we're going to have two warships
permanently based in the pacific uh
after this deployment it will go there
regularly it won't go there every year
um but i think it'll be an option for us
for what we want to do and it is
designed as are the reforms to our
commando force where traditionally we've
always seen our commandos in norway
so we made two groups called literal
response groups one for norway another
one will be called south and that will
be somewhere around the indian ocean and
the middle east uh almost permanently so
uh global britain will see more false
projection
i feel passionately and it is one of the
areas that i urge the united states
to to to still do
is presence matters
being forward and present in the world
matters it changes your adversary's
behavior you can't all do it from
sitting in tidworth you have to have
your bases in cyprus and you have to use
them you have to look for training
abroad in africa to be there so that any
moment of the year
i can say i have you know a battalion or
a battle group in the middle east or in
africa that matters if you want an army
to just sit there
uh you know ticking off how many tanks
it's got in tidworth you are not going
to influence very much
secretary of state we have overstayed
our welcome i know you have a busy day
down there in our headquarters
thank you for your time uh this morning
it's been a pleasure to talk to you and
you've teed up our further deliberations
perfectly with uh your remarks so i
thank you for that we'll let you get her
back to the day job